don't freak out don't sneeze and just
keep going so in about a few hours I
will be doing what I've been told is the
vampire official I'm one of those people
oh my oh hell no like that's [ __ ]
stupid that's crazy
why are people [ __ ] putting blood on
their face and then I got this little
guy but it's my birthday not appreciate
getting is it on my birthday so I was
like oh we are gonna put blood and all
the shit's on my face I ran from this
place right now I'm a little nervous I'm
a Latin boy from the city and I'm like I
don't know what all this [ __ ] is this is
some like rich people [ __ ] up again you
know look at that look at that looks
like science in there alright we'll see
how this i'm dr. shaw and we're here
today at next health we're gonna perform
a PRP with micro needling on you what
does that mean PRP is platelet-rich
plasma yes and what that is is we
actually take your blood and spin it in
the centrifuge yeah and then we separate
out the plasma the plasma is a part of
your blood that has all the growth
factors and we concentrate that up and
we put it into your skin does this hurt
I'm not gonna lie to you this is does
sting a little bit I feel like I'm about
to get onto a roller coaster so I'm like
mix of emotions my tummy's hurting a
little bit the results are really
fantastic some of the things that the
PRP really helps with is like acne
scarring pores fine lines and wrinkles
sun damage how much does a procedure
like this usually car so you know the
price range is around the towels amounts
to one procedure most people buy a
package of them so I could like skip a
few meals I lose weight and get really
good skin so you ready to do this I
guess I think so I'm scared but yes I'm
ready we'll take good care here so let's
go ahead and do this hey curly
my name is Ross I'm a registered nurse
here at Nick's help I'll be doing your
treatment today first thing we're gonna
do is apply your numbing cream this is a
blend of numbing cream couple different
types of light
here lather me I don't want to feel a
damn thing I feel like a cake and you're
just adding the frosting on my face
we're gonna let this absorb into your
skin for about 15 minutes while we draw
your bud and prepare the plasma I gotta
look completely away I'm teeth beautiful
so now I have the blood we're gonna spin
it for about 10 minutes we have a
centrifuge right there and you just hang
out and let that numb you couldn't take
effects all right Carly so your blood is
finished spinning this is what the tube
looks like efforts been centrifuge we
have all the red blood cells in the
bottom white blood cells in the middle
and then the plasma is at the top now
I'm applying your plasma this has all
the growth factors and nutrients that
are gonna really beautifully heal your
skin and then on top of that we're going
to do just a little bit of micro
needling here and this is gonna push all
those platelets growth factors in
between speaking to your skin okay it's
not like unbearable like I actually
really believe that you drawing the
blood was more painful than this is
you're definitely have like a red
sunburn appearance after this it doesn't
last very long about your day then maybe
day and a half all right curly the
treatments all finished I'm gonna give
you a little peek at what you look like
right now but this is not how you're
leaving our office oh this is gonna heal
so beautifully your skin textures gonna
be baby soft the pores are gonna be so
tiny overall you have this beautiful
radiance now we're gonna move you to the
next room we're gonna put on the
hyaluronic acid mask and do cryotherapy
and then we'll get you all cleaned up
and ready to go hi I'm Vanessa
how are you curly how is your facial I
feel like my face is throbbing a little
bit but in a good way
all right so we're gonna finish up the
rest of the facial this is in hyaluronic
acid mask hyaluronic acid helps with
moisture as well as plumping and it's
also gonna stimulate some collagen
growth we like to do it with the
cryotherapy so this is the cryo machine
it applies about negative 50
negative 20 degrees cold air and the
cold is what's going to have the skin
reacts and building more collagen oh
that feels nice
what kind of life have I been living
that I don't know about any of it
alright so now you're totally done
you're gonna look a little pink for the
next couple of days but that youthful
glow is gonna be there and it's only
gonna get better
so we just got done with the facial I
feel great I don't feel at any sort of
like soreness I don't feel any sort of
like tightness I don't feel each other
it feels really good and I highly
recommend it if you find yourself in a
place where you can try it definitely
try it let's see we'll see how I feel in
a few days so super interesting because
I'm super red and I'm back at work
and people are trying to be either
really nice and not saying anything at
all about my face or they're like whoa
what have you think about my face Korea
it's red yo it's itchy as [ __ ] educated
it is your gene this is d2 and you can't
really see him right here but I'm still
red I feel really tight and tender I've
been wearing this all day long
complaining about the thousand-dollar
facial he got on his birthday for free
no I'm not I feel like my skin looks a
lot better it doesn't it's not like a
crazy drastic but it definitely made me
consider taking more care of my skin I
think if you are gonna spend that much
money on a facial if you can definitely
do it definitely try it it's not gonna
like change you overnight but I think
it's the right direction in learning how
to self care and stuff like that
[Music]